all right in arizona deandre hopkins has
a new teammate aj
green joined the team via free agency
from the cincinnati bengals here's aj
green
talking about his new pass catching
teammate deandre hopkins
i never played with a guy like d-hop and
that's coming in meeting him
the guy is unbelievable man he embraced
me you know we don't have no egos he's
telling me like if you want to run
around and you know
and i'm at this position just let me
know so you have a guy like that two
guys like that in the room man it's
gonna be unbelievable we feed off each
other
there's no denying and there's no
doubting the skills and abilities of
deandre hopkins the irony
in that comment is the
presumption that aj green is still aj
green that's the question everyone has
and
maybe he is maybe he is but it's
completely fair based on the past
several years for us to say
aj green remembers aj green julio jones
aj green julio jones drafted the same
year drafted the top ten
julio jones is still julio jones aj
green hasn't been aj green for a while
no it's been at least up
three years right i mean because he was
hurt two years ago then last year was
underwhelming
you know yeah i mean he's one of the
more special specimens
uh freaks of nature that we've ever had
at the wide receiver position in the nfl
i mean he's one of those guys mike
that classifies of like the woe factor
where
you get on a practice field or a game
field and you say see aj green it's up
there with the julio jones or the randy
mosses of the andre johnsons where you
just go what
is that guy really that big and that
fast and that quick is that that makes
sense
i mean he's special that way but he's
like the biggest question in the nfl
maybe at the wide receiver position to
to piggyback off of what you said
i mean it's an ultimate boom or bust you
know scenario here
aj green last year it was good but like
you said it certainly wasn't great
there was drop balls and it looked like
there was still
a little bit of a lack of explosion or
something from the foot
injury from the year before so that's
that is gonna be the million dollar
question
and i just with arizona in general i
think that's one of the intriguing
things
they got kind of like two of those guys
on their roster right now
him aj green we're not sure what he's
gonna be if he's
if he's close to what he used to be then
whoa watch out
but even the the second round pick they
got uh mike rondell moore
i know we talked about him a little in
the draft he's been hurt in college
football the last two years
he was a freak show as a freshman he was
kind of as a sophomore and junior
but dealing with injuries i mean if they
have those two come together
and you can spread the field with
hopkins aj green rondell moore christian
kirk
and then you got kyler murray at shotgun
with a four wide set
wow have fun defenses i mean have fun
defensive coordinators get your tylenol
because you're going to have headaches
all week long trying to figure that out
one point about aj green i'm looking at
his statistical
accomplishments it was a big deal this
year when mike evans became the first
receiver in league history to have a
thousand yards for
seven straight seasons to begin his
career aj greene would have been the
first
but he only had 964 yards in 2016 when
he only played in 10 games think about
that 96 964 yards in
10 games he would have sailed over a
thousand yards and then the wheels came
off 2017
he had a thousand yards but then 2018
694
in nine games didn't play in 2019 at all
last year
he played in every game he was targeted
104 times
47 catches 523 yards that's 32.6 yards
per game that is a dramatic fall
yeah over the last couple of years we
haven't seen the best of aj green
in four years it and it's a calculated
risk by the cardinals that they're gonna
they're gonna draw it out of him maybe
they will maybe they won't but i think
that's one of the big questions
for you know a guy who had to linger on
the market chris because
yeah nobody really knows what he has
left no nobody does and he had a hard
like time connecting with joe burrow
last year too a little bit like that
baker mayfield odell beckham jr where
it's like both of them were nervous or
they couldn't get on the same page or
whatever it was
but it's certainly when you turn on the
film of aj green yes it's not the same
guy it does not have the same explosion
top end speed any of that hopefully
you know another year of playing a year
away from that
that foot injury maybe he's back
at least as the athletic specimen close
to what he's
what he what he was before that injury
we'll see but that is that's a huge
question
uh because they're one of those teams
that you know that works out
they're going to be a major player of
course in the nfc and the nfc west and
it'll be a handful trying to figure out
how to guard that def
or that offense but there's some big
question marks there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports